[Music]
since its formation the earth has been
revolving west to east on its axis if
one day our planet started rotating in
the opposite direction it would no
longer be the earth as we know it in
what ways would a clockwise rotation
change the earth and why would you end
up living in a desert this is what if
and here's what would happen if the
earth started spinning backwards you
don't notice it but our planet spins
pretty fast 460 meters per second as
measured at the equator a sudden change
of direction would cause disastrous
winds and massive waves together these
abnormal weather conditions would wipe
out nearly everything above the ground
let's just skip over this destroying
transition imagine our planet reversed
its direction billions of years ago
you'd see the Sun and the moon rise in
the West and said in the east and you'd
never believe that the Sahara could be a
desert how different would our planet
turn out to be short answer the reverse
spin would make earth much greener long
answer this new rotation would change
winds and ocean currents and that would
shift the planet's climate entirely
oceans work as a global climate control
distributing the sun's heat all over the
earth they divert moisture from the
driest hottest Badlands and carry
rainfall to thorny jungles if the earth
reversed its rotation one very important
climate driving current would disappear
from the Atlantic Ocean instead a
different current would surface in the
Pacific and become responsible for
distributing heat around the globe
this new current would make the deserts
retreat from africa and eurasia you'd
have to go to the other side of the
planet to do some quadbiking on the
golden landscape more specifically to
Brazil the US would also get very arid
in the south but none of the new Barrens
would be anywhere close to how dry the
Sahara Desert is now there'd be much
more vegetation covering the planet hey
that's more oxygen for all of us but
those living in Western Europe would be
in for a shock the Pacific current would
push a lot of cold water that way
bringing freezing winters to the region
Russia on the other hand would warm up
and take a break from being the coldest
country on earth life on the reverse
spinning earth would be different to in
the oceans cyanobacteria would dominate
over other phytoplankton species
billions of years ago the oxygen pumping
cyanobacteria invented photosynthesis
and transformed our planet's atmosphere
maybe having so much more cyanobacteria
on earth would alter the atmosphere even
further filling it up with too much
oxygen for us to even exist let's just
leave the planet to spin the way it does
and what if it stops rotating altogether
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]